[Music]
this one gets slightly controversial but
that's exactly why we're here to discuss
it i thought you said it wasn't gonna be
serious no more there was a woman who
sued her mother's general practitioner
due to a wrongful conception and has
successfully won the right to
compensation
what was the conception what's a
wrongful conception so this chick's name
compensation
[Laughter]
what court did they go to
and then they use contraception
i don't know any other words
i didn't put it in a sentence but yeah
it's pretty good consternation what's it
mean consternation who knows over
constipation
and domination
all right i like this compilation [ __ ]
all right compilation yeah i got to keep
them on tumbs age 20 from lincolnshire
was born with spina bifida where a
baby's spine and spinal cord fail to
develop in the womb which causes a gap
and she's suing her doctor dr philip
mitchell over wrong conception charge
blaming him for not advising her mother
caroline to take the required
supplements prior to getting pregnant to
reduce the risk of spina bifida
so they didn't they didn't do anything
about it and then she turned out what is
that what is that thing you get a spinal
gap
so you can do this really good
oh really
is she a dancer it sounds like a great
musical
it's fine
a great music
what's the plot of spina bifida i don't
know it's probably a cirque du soleil
show
[Laughter]
and they're all wearing like medical
bars
those are all like single syllable
almost what happens when you have this
guy just bifida bifida is kind of funny
like what are what are the downsides
size can you walk up yeah uh twisto flex
is a a pro that comes out of it you
automatically go to the finals at funk
styles gems
oh that's one so you learn
is that one of the ways to be as good as
pop and pete
you might have a bunch that's an unfair
advantage so uh it says that the nerves
that control the leg muscles don't work
properly below the area of the spina
bifida defect this can cause muscle
weakness of the legs and sometimes
paralysis whether a child can walk
typically depends on where the defect is
its size and the care received before
and after yeah so that's why they [ __ ]
up yeah
i mean are they paralyzed or what
because my i can't fathom what the [ __ ]
is happening well actually she is not
paralyzed she's got a horse she actually
is a jockey
so she's actually capable of doing
phenomenal things is she really small
she can she is really small she's really
short she competes in uh dude hell yeah
jockey
kind of like the paralympics almost but
i don't think she's in the olympics but
yeah stuff like that
but yeah she's just pretty much suing
her mom's general practitioner for
millions of dollars yeah and now she is
awarded the right to compensation
cause she's like i came out with a
spinal bit bitter
yes yes but do you guys you guys feel
like that's like totally
legit yeah i have a friend i have a
friend who's sued who sued a doctor for
something like that similar but um like
something happened where his arm didn't
develop correctly because they forgot to
they did something wrong during the
delivery and then he he got a large
settlement like later in life when they
determined was it like he had already
developed as like a child within the
womb because
with this am i
maybe i'm incorrect with it but is this
something like before you even get
pregnant uh you have to take certain
stuff i think it's like if they if it
comes out in the in the assessment or in
like the data that this thing is there
they're liable to like treat it and if
they don't then that's where they [ __ ]
up well we're we're agreeing a lot on
this so let me i'll be my friend bar
quan
yeah what would bart say i think that
it's kind of [ __ ] up that like
you could sue a doctor just because
you don't know
if you're a doctor you're a person too
you can make a mistake and then you know
it [ __ ] up your whole life
that's like the most unintelligent
version of art that's what i would say
something like that yes in that vein
bart has so much empathy to the point
where he doesn't he was like maybe maybe
the doctor was having a bad day that day
maybe that's what happened maybe he had
a stomach ache and he misdiagnosed so
what you're seeing
[Laughter]
take the pills maybe the mom's like no i
don't want to maybe she's anti-pills but
then what's telling your daughter
i don't take pills dude she's a big
anti-pillar doctors aren't allowed to be
like whoopsie yeah i think that's what
there's a whoopsie insurance that's what
that is oops malpractice oops oh that's
oh whoopsie interesting i forget there
are like terrible [ __ ] dogs something
in place so a doctor can actually say
whoops you know maybe it's not a good
idea to
sleep deprived doctors and overwork them
with what kind of difficult [ __ ] they
have to deal with then they should just
get paid less so they don't have to work
as much that's pretty good yeah is it is
it because uh we don't have enough
doctors as what it is
somebody in the medical industry please
tell me yeah lawrence
um yeah yeah there's there's two little
doctors as someone who plays doctor
and
as an actor
you know it sort of sucks for doctors
too because like they have to be perfect
right if they make one mistake they're
just [ __ ] right yeah that's what my
friend mark was just saying like minor
mistakes like oh your stitches got one
extra stitch or you know what i mean
like i think little things like that
maybe i don't know yeah but but all
doctors were all like [ __ ] human
right they're just gonna they're gonna
[ __ ] up and it's just like it's scary to
be a doctor i like the one where they're
doing surgery and then they actually
leave the surgery tools inside the
person yes
let's stitch it back up and like
let's go get eight happy hour let's go
that happened too my friend was a doctor
[ __ ] i forget the exact story but um
left the scissors inside yes oh [ __ ]
good guess um she she caught it another
doctor um
was just saying like yeah she's just
complaining about stuff like just
[ __ ] release her like uh we don't
need to do any more x-rays but then the
lady was like screaming in pain and my
friend she's like all right we'll just
[ __ ] do an x-ray [ __ ] save that
doctor's life because the other doctor
was like nah [ __ ] it she's fine she's
good she's good
oh my god in her in her [ __ ] after
surgery they left a [ __ ] scissor in
her [ __ ] that's [ __ ] nuts is it
like kitchen scissors like big buggers
like big [ __ ] not no
it was a
clairos
the fabric yeah yeah yeah
she found the scissors she found this
it's like the silly one
the wiggly one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cool designs on
the page because organs have different
squiggles and stuff yeah you can imagine
you got to match the squiggles to the
organs yeah the little uh thing that
spins your hair out i also think with
doctors too a lot of the times they get
pressured to discharge their patients
really quick so a lot of times it makes
them go like all right i'm gonna look
through this really quick all right
you're good to go next just talk about
some more americans
my uncle was getting surgery and they
left a manscaped inside of him
4.0 use the promo code jkd this episode
is brought to you by his uncle we
haven't been [ __ ] manscaped for a
while so don't promote their [ __ ] sorry
sorry yeah dude you know that [ __ ] still
[ __ ] like
tweaks at me like nick's at you yeah it
still nicks me hey you can't say it on
camera
sorry
it was probably the manscape 1.0 yeah
that's what it was not the 4.0 let's get
a 2.0 maybe bleed too
the funny thing is like if you
personally know any doctors or nurses or
anybody in medical field the most you
hear about fuck-up stories i think
that's hilarious yeah that means
everybody [ __ ] up they're not gonna
tell you their success stories because
those are the most issues
like you know
who do like
anesthetic or any and whatever you
[ __ ] say
anastasia or romano they talk about all
these times they have to [ __ ] save
another dude for [ __ ] up the uh
amount
because you know you could just kill
someone instantly and there's a lot of
time where he's like dude i barely
[ __ ] caught it my co-worker put the
switch the values and had it backwards
bro that's what happened holy jesus
that's not even the surgeon that's just
the dude knocking you out so he's
knocking you out and he's like okay
romano's macaroni grill happy hour
hold on let me finish this endless trip
here we go
like all the [ __ ] up stories are crazy
dude
i was like what other restaurants is
steve gonna name
you
have you guys have you guys heard about
the
the dr death stories have you of course
jack of working yeah like oh not jack
wait no not actually not him there was
another one that's actually his name was
also dr death too but there was a guy in
houston texas who was like he was a
surgeon and he was killing people
under the knife and then they just kept
moving them to different hospitals
he was a catholic [ __ ] and he he
killed like hundreds of people there was
like a whole pocket what was he doing
just killing people he's on accident
just like yeah [ __ ] up malpractice
you know that type of [ __ ] but they just
kept like all right let's send them over
here and send them over here whoa so
it's like i don't know man
sometimes scissors get people stuck in
people's heads i don't get sick and i
don't go to the hospital
i don't let doctors kill me man i don't
let doctors tell them was it recently
that one girl got a
breast augmentation she died because of
the anesthesiologist put the wrong
amount oh holy ghost she was just
getting a boob job dying it's like a
young chick too right yeah yeah young
asian chicken yeah oh dang that's not a
good way to go no not volunteering
that's how kanye's mama died oh no
that's how she died yeah yeah yeah
getting back breast surgeries
breast surgery or breast like i think
augmentation i think oh and then what
went wrong nobody knows let's look it up
i had a friend go through it and she
said her body was like rejecting the
titties for a while and so she was like
down and out like shaking and like all
that kind of stuff my friend she had to
take him out yeah that's pretty cool
it's like a percentage yeah there's a
small percentage of where your body
won't
pain it's like an autoimmune response
huh beautiful pain
the things they had to do for those fun
bags
my body rejected my circumcision when i
got it
because you got it too late
my foreskin just like came back
it's still growing to this day
just a mock turtleneck into a full
it got longer
so i can gap commercial stop motion oh
[ __ ]
you trim them every month so that they
get longer
i'm gonna keep going back
it's like a crinkled straw thing where
you put water on it
i still do that
i love doing that that's fun just for
the facts it says for donda aka kanye's
mom after undergoing liposuction and a
breast reduction donda then 58 left the
operating room apparently in good health
but died at home the next day
oh so you don't know what did it well it
wasn't a breast tim it was apparently a
heart failure due to the post-operative
uh procedures and stuff whoa no
yeah that's what [ __ ] kanye up man
after that he wasn't the same
he's uh yeah he's special that's that's
for sure was that is that really that
was the moment that that makes sense i
guess
[Music]
you